io vi ringrazio innanzitutto di essere
qui ad ascoltare queste poche parole
cercherò di dire
futuro della scuola un futuro che già
c'è da 100 anni esiste già però ancora
troppo piccolo bisogna farlo crescere un
pochino
io cercherò di dire qualche cosa su una
scuola che può essere migliore noi tutti
abbiamo avuto un'esperienza scolastica
almeno credo che quelli che stanno in
questa sala abbiano avuto delle
esperienze scolastiche nella loro vita
di solito è un'esperienza scolastica
molto tradizionale appunto ognuno di voi
se chiude gli occhi per cinque secondi
riesce ad immaginare un aula con un
docente un banco una lavagna una materia
un argomento un compito da svolgere una
valutazione e c'è qualcosa che ritorna
cioè questo uno che è un po ossessivo
che ritorna dobbiamo fare tutti la
stessa cosa dobbiamo fare tutti nello
stesso momento e la scuola sembra
strutturata su questa idea che tutti
quanti dobbiamo fare la stessa cosa
nello stesso momento
in realtà ci sono tanti modi di fare le
cose si possono fare anche tante cose
diverse e ognuno di noi può fare una
cosa diversa dalla persona che gli ha
accanto in questo stesso momento non c'è
necessità di fare tutti quanti geografia
nello stesso momento di fare tutti
quanti stare nello stesso momento di
risolvere tutti quanti un problema
algebrico nello stesso momento per
imparare la geografia per imparare
l'algebra la grande differenza che gli
esseri umani hanno alla nascita e che
mantengono durante tutta la vita
la scuola cerca di cancellarla ci riesce
non tutta la scuola la scuola
tradizionale come un lp in un'area in
cui c'erano dodici canzoni
c'erano due canzoni magnifiche le altre
10 e si dovevano mettere perché vendere
solo due canzoni in un lp era un po
difficile non si poteva non si poteva
fare dice l'unesco che nel mondo 58
milioni di bambini e bambine soprattutto
bambini non vanno a scuola
e chiaro che per quei bambini anche una
scuola tradizionale e meglio per non
andare a scuola
in questo momento non stanno giocando
probabilmente stanno
morando probabilmente stanno avendo
anche degli incidenti sul lavoro quindi
non il mio discorso non è un discorso
contro la scuola è un discorso a favore
della scuola ma di una scuola diversa
qualcuno diceva un altro mondo è
possibile un altro modo non lo so io mi
occupo di scuola per le un'altra scuola
però è possibile questo questo
sicuramente
oltre a questo dato che è un dato
impressionante di 58 milioni i bambini
di bambini di bambini che non vanno a
scuola
però dobbiamo tenere presente un altro
dato ci sono milioni di bambini di
bambine che danno in una scuola dove si
annoiano e un francese una volta ha
detto sia la noia fosse arte le scuole
sarebbero dei musei sono dei musei molto
ricchi tra l'altro non musei dove c'è un
solo pezzo bello
l'inglese di pezzi e ne sono molti e
molto interessanti è evidente che quando
chiediamo diciamo a qualcuno mannaggia
nerica oggi non possiamo andare a
giocare a pallone e tutti i bambini
dicono ma no ma come ci eravamo
preparati volevamo andare a giocare a
pallone
cosa invece si dice è oggi nevica gli
autobus non girano non si può andare a
scuola e disegni dei bambini non
piangono non si strappa i capelli perché
non possono andare a scuola
questo è un dato molto indicativo e
tutti noi abbiamo fatto esperienze come
queste e vediamo i nostri figli che
fanno esperienze come queste
dobbiamo tenerlo presente quando
progettiamo la scuola perché la scuola è
qualcosa che la società ha sempre dovuto
progettare la scuola che però noi
abbiamo un eredità dai nostri antenati e
non può essere la scuola che daremo in
eredità a i nostri figli perché è una
scuola che ha una metafora la sua base
che una metafora molto antica e la
metafora del vaso che deve essere
riempito
e quindi c'è l'idea che il bambino la
bambina siano come dei vasi vuoti e che
l'adulto sia un vaso invece molto più
grande e con molta acqua che può versare
all'interno del vaso più piccolo una
quantità di liquido
finché il vaso è pronto a recepire acqua
si riempie si riempe arriva un limite e
dopo di che non può più ricevere acqua
questa metafora però
una metafora molto molto primitiva un po
rettiliana si dice anche oggi usiamo una
parte del cervello quando immaginiamo
queste cose che probabilmente non
riguarda la neocorteccia riguarda
qualcosa di più antico
ecco questo tipo di scuola è una scuola
che è nata con l'industrialismo è nata
perché ognuno doveva fare qualche cosa e
non doveva occuparsi di quello che
stavano facendo gli altri era
sufficiente svolgere il compito di
matematica in quel momento avere la
risposta esatta all'equazione e tutto
quanto rientrava negli schemi e
interessante perché in tutte le culture
del mondo
meglio in molte culture del mondo c'è
una figura popolare che è quella del
bambino impertinente in italia il
bambino impertinente si chiama pierino
di solito no e allora c'è la maestra che
vi dice pierino su un ramo ci sono tre
uccellini e poi arriva il cacciatore
attenzione perino spara colpisce un
uccellino e l'uccellino muore e cade dal
ramo quanti uccellini rimangono sul ramo
pierino periodo era mentre fa nessuno
pierino aspettati rifaccio di riforma
una domanda la domanda è ci sono tre
uccellini sul ramo il cacciatore spara
uno muore cade dal ramo quanti ne
rimangono sul ramo pierino e per insiste
nessuno maestra ma guarda pierino mi
dispiace la risposta esatta era due no
maestra mi scusi quando il cacciatore
spara gli altri due uccellini che non
sono scemi volano via
quindi bravo non mi rimane proprio
nessuno ecco come sempre tutte fanno
molto di nei bambini infatti considerata
adulti non avete riso mi fa piacere
bisogna dei bambini sono molto contenti
perché per che smaschera qualcosa
l'impertinenza di questo bambino di
questo tirino smaschera una filosofia
che una cattiva filosofia una gattina
filosofia quella che prevede che le
domande contengono già la risposta le
domande non devono volta in una risposta
sono negative domande quando ci facciamo
una domanda a cui tutti c'è un problema
nel chi pone la domanda non per chi non
sa dare la risposta corretta ecco la
scuola per secoli è stata progettata
così c'era qualcuno che aveva le
risposte immaginava delle domande che
potevano andare bene per quelle risposte
faceva delle lezioni frontali spiegava
quali erano le risposte giuste alle
domande giuste
dopo di che andava a controllare se
tutti quelli che avevano ascoltato
quella lezione erano in grado di
rispondere in maniera corretta
di solito non più del 20 per cento delle
persone che vengono sottoposte a questo
trattamento che si potrebbe dire inumano
riescono a dare risposte corrette con
metodi diversi invece ci sono dei
livelli di benessere e delle e dei
livelli d'apprendimento molto diversi
molto più alti di maggiore qualità è
inutile stare a progettare un unica
risposta ad un'unica domanda è un unico
modo di risolvere i problemi a problemi
già risolti in passato perché questa
cosa non riguarda il futuro e non
riguarda la nostra vita e quando quel
pierino dice no ma guardi mestre che
portano via gli uccelli sta dicendo ma
la società di cosa si preoccupa del
fatto che io riesca a rispondere alle
sfide che ogni giorno la vita mette di
fronte o che io sia in grado di ripetere
come si dice anche a pappagallo no cioè
senza essere consapevoli di quello che
stiamo dicendo alcune cose che mi sono
state insegnate da altri in un momento
in cui probabilmente ero interessato a
fare altro e allora è interessante per
questo è un diritto umano fondamentale
se io vi chiedessi quale è la risorsa
più importante per l'umanità
voi probabilmente inizierete a pensare
un sol petrolio
l'acqua la fertilità della terra
probabilmente invece la risorsa più
importante per l'umanità e la voglia di
apprendere che hanno tutti i bambini e
le bambine quando nascono e che
naturalmente se non siamo cattivi
educatori mantengono durante tutto
l'arco della vita
questa cosa è veramente la risorsa più
importante per l'umanità
io non posso immaginare che il petrolio
valga di più o che valga di più il
denaro o che ci siano investimenti che
rendono di più il umanesimo più grande è
proprio questo è creare delle condizioni
umane per gli esseri umani
la scuola troppo spesso ha dimenticato
che bisogna creare condizioni umane e
che i bambini e le bambine hanno una
naturale propensione apprende
ora c'è una grande italiana che ha
scoperto questa cosa ora non per creare
italiana si può essere di qualsiasi
nazionalità per scoprire qualcosa perché
le nazionalità sono cose che vengono
inventate in maniera un po assurdo dagli
esseri umani però la montessori che
appunto le è capitato di nascere
italiana ha scoperto alcune cose molto
interessanti sull'apprendimento e si è
accorta che non bisognava adattare il
bambino alla scuola ma adattare la
scuola il bambino è un processo molto
semplice lo facciamo nella vita di tutti
i giorni
prepariamo il caffè lo facciamo in un
certo modo
alla fine delle mire fuori caffè il
metodo è semplice non si può inventare
ogni giorno o andare contro le leggi
della fisica
dobbiamo seguire alcuni procedimenti il
primo procedimento quando si progetta la
scuola e partire da che cosa il bambino
che cosa la bambina qual è la
caratteristica principale dell'essere
umano e la volontà di apprendere aveva
montessori nel 1907 a roma si è accorta
di alcune cose le ha scoperte non le ha
inventate
infatti se vi capita di leggere un libro
molto bello stesso richiamo alla
scoperta del bambino perché ci sono cose
che all'improvviso si scoprono qualcuno
dopo di me so che parla di scoperte e di
cose che si scoprono la nota essere ha
scoperto che i bambini potevano fare
cose diverse
qualcuno la geografia mentre qualcuno fa
una tematica potevano lavorare insieme
prima di me è stato detto il primo
motivo per cui non si fa innovazione e
che si ha paura che gli altri ci rubino
le idee è normale perché scuola ci
insegnano questo cosa invece è normale
collaborare con gli altri si apprende
dagli altri e ci si accorge che c'è uno
scambio continuo nell'apprendimento
i bambini possono fare queste cose e la
molte strade si accorse nel 1907 che
portavano un grande frutto alla persona
umana le persone ma ne crescevano e
mantenevano la voglia di scoprire e di
apprendere grazie al fatto che
l'ambiente educativo era pensato per
favorire i tratti tipici dell'essere
umano che sono la voglia di conoscere
l'interesse la passione quando
affrontiamo le cose ci accorgiamo che
bello è bello affrontare i problemi è
bello fare è bello risolvere bello porsi
degli obiettivi fallire ripartire fare
errori capire come funziona le cose
e tutto questo la montessori lo
sfruttava diceva sì facciamone lavorare
in gruppi perché non possono le elezioni
diminuiamo le ore in cui facciamo
lezione facciamo più ricerca come è
possibile solo parlare
mettiamo tanti materiali la matematica
ci saranno dei materiali triangoli
facciamoli di legno facciamo ritoccare
bambini e tutto questo generava una
grande passione e gli apprendimenti
nascevano in maniera naturale e non
perché era qualcosa che doveva uscire
fuori dalla macchina che produceva
conoscenze nei bambini
bisogna stare molto attenti quando si
parla di scuola perché ci focalizziamo
quasi esclusivamente sui risultati sui
prodotti mentre la scuola per i bambini
e le bambine non è un risultato non è un
prodotto è qualcosa che stanno vivendo
adesso è un processo
se noi la pensiamo come una fabbrica che
deve produrre dei prodotti
ci stiamo dimenticando che invece un
luogo di vita dove bisogna stare bene e
sfruttare le proprie potenzialità per
crescere sempre di più insieme agli
altri
io cerco di dire un'ultima cosa molto
importante perché crea futuro la scuola
fa futuro una scuola come questa
una scuola in cui gli esseri umani hanno
diritto a sfruttare le loro naturali
tendenze perché è una scuola in cui i
bambini e le bambine hanno la
possibilità di entrare in contatto con
l'universo intero soltanto a scuola
esiste l'ora di matematica allora di
musica e l'ora di letteratura questa
frammentazione delle discipline dei
saperi e qualcosa di assurdo perché
nella vita di tutti i giorni
non esiste un momento in cui utilizzo
competenze matematiche 1 in cui utilizzo
competenze di musica e uno è qui invece
mi serve la letteratura perché nello
stesso momento anche io adesso sto
parlando
devo stare attento alla prosodia devo
stare attento a quante parole di quanto
velocemente le dico
devo cercare delle figure retoriche e
delle tecniche che ritengano che vi
tengono svegli e queste sono competenze
che sono interdisciplinari allora
bisogna fare
molta molta attenzione quando si parla
di scuola perché diamo per scontate
troppe cose che vengono dal passato e
che non ci porteranno verso il futuro
ma ci lasceranno indietro indietro di
parecchio prima comparivano una scritta
una frase che dice bisogna guardare
avanti per non rimanere indietro
eccetera eccetera bisogna guardare
avanti perché altrimenti si va a
sbattere contro muro che queste il
tripudio per cui bisogna andare a
guardare avanti
la scuola sta guardando ad un modello
che sa che è molto vecchio molto anziano
e non esiste più le fabbriche sono
cambiate prima di me hanno parlato di
un'economia che ormai a green
quando pensiamo alla prima la seconda
industrializzazione immaginiamo delle
ciminiere che inquinano oggi quando
pensiamo ad una fabbrica pensiamo ad una
startup pensiamo a dei ragazzi e delle
ragazze che si sono messe insieme per
realizzare qualcosa con delle stampanti
3d o con l'internet of things e quindi
il mondo cambia la scuola anche deve
cambiare l'ultima cosa che volevo dire
questa la montessori e alla fine della
sua vita però si accorge che la scuola
non solo può far star bene i bambini e
la scuola può adattarsi alla mente del
bambino e della bambina ma la scuola
riesce anche in un intento in cui
fallisce di solito la politica in cui
falliscono
di solito gli investitori privati e in
cui invece la scuola riesce molto
facilmente la montessori va in india la
fine della sua vita e viene fatta
prigioniera di guerra dagli inglesi
perché l'italiano appunto e alla fine
della sua vita in india si accorge che i
bambini e le bambine delle scuole
elementari avevano la fortuna di non
stare in città e quindi di andare in
giro raccoglie le piante vedere come
erano fatte le radici delle piante e
andare a cercare gli insetti facevano i
terrai ci mettevano le rane vedevano se
la rana cosa mangiava la rana quanto
saltava e vedendo questi bambini che si
appassionavano alle scienze naturali
possiamo dire noi della chiamava
educazione cosmica e si accorse che
l'essere umano quando è piccolo se viene
messo in contatto con l'universo viene
messo in contatto con la più grande
risorsa immateriale che l'umanità a lui
diverso è tutto da conoscere non è
infinito però immenso la nostra mente
non è infinita una capacità infinita è
però ha capacità immense ogni bambino
messo a contatto con l'universo si
indirizzerà verso la conoscenza di
qualche aspetto del reale la filosofia
la matematica della musica la produzione
della chimica di un aspetto del reale si
interesserà crescerà e otterrà questa
risorsa immateriale che vi permetterà di
scoprire che le forze sono tutte quante
interdipendenti e che questa
interdipendenza crea una grande armonia
amerà l'universo e sarà fratello di
tutti gli altri e creerà una società di
pace perché si accorgeva che la cosa più
importante da possedere e il materiale e
la conoscenza e la cosa più bella da
fare è essere in relazione con gli altri
questo la scuola riesce a farlo si è una
scuola umana che crea condizioni umane e
sicuramente una scuola come questa ha
molto futuro perché crea futuro anche
per l'umanità
la metafora che c'è dietro non è più
quella del vaso che deve essere riempito
l'adulto deve riempire la testa di
questi bambini dicendogli devi sapere
chi era napoleone devi sapere che cos'è
l'equazione di primo grado e quindi devo
riempire dei vasi la metafora una
metafora diversa
non si tratta più di riempire qualcosa
ma si tratta di passare il testimone di
far sì che il fuoco che abbiamo dentro
accendo altri fuochi grazie